Mrs. Kruthers, welcome.
Thank you.
Come on in, have a seat.
Of course.
I have been looking over your resume and I have to say I am very impressed.
Oh, thank you.
You know, actually I think, to be honest, you are overqualified to be an accountant.
Oh well, that's okay, I don't intend to work very hard.
Really?
Absolutely! In fact, I only intend to show up when I feel like it,...
...which is good because I've a wide variety of extremely annoying personal habits...
...and absolutely no sense of hygiene.
Oh! You know, then I don't feel like you're the correct person for this position.
That's okay, I quit.
You can't quit, you don't work here.
Like, I would ever work here.
Like, we would ever hire you.
Oh yeah?
Yeah. And even if you did work here...
...I wouldn't even give you the opportunity to quit because I would fire you.
Well, you can't fire me because I don't work here.
That's right! You don't and I would can your ass so quick.
Prove it.
Okay. You've got the job.
Thank you.
You're welcome and now it is my pleasure to inform you that...
I quit.
You can't quit, I fired you.
No, it's too late I don't work here anymore.
Fine, let's try this again.
You've got the job and now you're fired.
No, you offered me the job but I never accepted.
Look, I've already worked for you, it's very tedious.
And now you want me back I think it's a regressive career move.
Okay, what can we do to get you to come work for us?
A raise.
A raise?
$200 an hour.
200 an hour? Okay, prorated to this ten seconds you're gonna be working here so, 12 cents?
And this time I promise I won't quit.
You promise you won't quit, you promise you'll let me fire you.
If you still want to.
I'm sure I'm going to want to.
So, we have a deal?
Not yet.
I've already been an accountant here.
I feel like I've outgrown the position.
I want something higher.
How about Junior Vice President?
Junior Vice President? $200 an hour or 12 cents whichever comes first...
...and you promise not to quit before I have the opportunity to fire you.
That's correct.
Great! You've got the job.
I accept.
Great! Now, you're fired.
You can't fire me, I'm Junior Vice President. I'm your boss.
Well, that doesn't make sense.
And as your boss, I regret that I have to fire you.
Why are you firing me?
Well, I can't help but notice that as head of personnel...
...you've been hiring some very strange people lately, at $200 an hour for me.
What am I supposed to do without a job?
Well, we do have a new position opening up in head of personnel.
Do you have any experience?